how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some news about doctor strange and the
multiverse of
madness and how one division is going to
connect to it doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and one division
are two of the most anticipated projects
of phase four especially since the two
of them are going to connect together
and we'll see wanda become the scarlet
witch for the very first time
in the mcu and she'll play a big role in
doctor strange too but as it turns out
she's not going to be
alone as two other people who just so
happen to be mutants in the comics are
going to be joining her
in doctor strange 2 as well and this
gives us a little bit of an idea of
what's going to take place in the
wanavision series and we'll break it all
down in this video but first big
congratulations to last week's hawkeye
funko pop winner
ivan pasquale del pobile sorry if i
butchered your name
but email me in the email in my
description and we'll get you your funko
pop and for this week's giveaway i'm
giving away a gladiator hulk funko pop
so all you have to do to enter subscribe
to my channel like this video and leave
a comment down below
also i'm giving away five funko pops on
my instagram and twitter for the next
four weeks so be sure to follow me on
there as well to enter
so to dive right into this report it's
coming from mcucosmic.com
and the report says that we've known for
a long time that wiccan and speed are
going to be making their mcu debut in
the one division series
and we've also known that wanda is going
to be making her way into doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness and
apparently according to a very reliable
source she's going to be bringing her
twin boys with her
so wiccan and speed the two mutant boys
of wanda and vision are going to be
characters in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness now this means a
couple of different things
one thing is that they're going to
progressively age in the one division
series
and the brief big game tv spot that they
showed during the super
bowl marvel gave us a tiny little
glimpse into the one division series and
we did in fact
see her twin boys but they were infants
however
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness they're going to be
teenagers but this is not going to be
because the one division series is going
to take place
over the next 15 or so years what's
actually going to happen
is that in the one division series her
boys are going to age
very progressively and according to what
we've heard we're going to see
essentially three or so different
versions of them we'll see them as
babies then we'll see them around the
age of 10 to 12
and then we'll see them as teenagers and
that's when they'll go into doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
we know this because of the casting
calls
for the twin boys the casting calls
asked for different age groups and
that's how we know what age groups to
expect so in the one division series
we'll see them age very quickly now the
second thing that's pretty important
is that the two of them joining doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
makes
three new teenage heroes because america
chavez is going to be in the movie as
well
so that makes three young avengers in
one
movie making it pretty obvious that the
young avengers are going to be a pretty
big priority for marvel studios moving
forward two of the other young avengers
are getting their very own disney plus
shows miss marvel and kate bishop as
it's been confirmed that the hawkeye
series is really going to be about
hawkeye training a new hawkeye
kate bishop we then have cassie lang
ant-man's daughter he was supposed to
come in and be
stature as well then there have been
rumors of hulk lane appearing in the
wanda vision series and king the
conqueror appearing in the loki series
this would all perfectly set up the
young avengers and the fact that all of
these characters are rumored to come in
phase four
means that we could see an official
young avengers team come together in
phase five
after all as reported we're going to
have three of the young avengers in one
film and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness so it looks like
doctor strange and america chavez are
going to be getting some help from wanda
and her boys in their movie
so let me know what you think about this
in the comments down below
are you excited to see wiccan and speed
join their mother in doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness and are you
excited for the young avengers to come
to the mcu
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all of the latest
mcu news as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof
you